oh [ __ ] is a dude here classics of class
what's the hell's going on here what's
going on here does that happen to you to
[ __ ] is going on fine isn't it is that a
dude in the gorilla suit Ursa legged is
throwing smoke bombs what wash I this is
this guy's my life Santos is called [ __ ]
what's out here
hey Rob handle re hey Danny thanks so
much for having me on today no problem
you're a massive GTA found here in the
gamespot offices I am a fanatic i love
it you play this game like a crazy bad
in fact i believe a crazy man dressed as
some sort of Christmas elf yeah I'm
elfin it you lunatic it's New Years Eve
Danny and I thought it would be best if
we got all our kicks out okay so weak
you know some of the most popular new
year's resolutions we could just do the
exact opposite of those oh so we're just
gonna get it out of our system you know
fun stuff I like it I spent quite a lot
of this year jumping at helicopters and
all I should probably quit that next
year so yeah lets us go ahead and get in
and start with that day sounds pretty
good to me oh good I thought we could go
and check out the local there you are
check out the local fitness center okay
yeah and just kill everyone there yeah
because we could screw that screw that
dam january first is when will actually
start being fit but until then we should
do the exact opposite mode and ruin
everyone's time oh yeah oh [ __ ] i
[ __ ] turn up elfin it you're gonna
say elfin it every time you do something
you can wear I would know it oh you got
ears and everything oh yeah and they're
anatomically correct Santa would be
proud where's the gym the gym is uh oh
Jesus I just got knocked down by some oh
my gosh guy you better shoot that guy
now that's something the White him up ah
damn no one here there's no one here no
one here I can't believe even muscles be
jam it all you want to work out and we
work out by okay nice died of bullets
[ __ ] your face dick Merry Christmas
filthy animal all right so we should
probably not rob many more cars next
year but for the moment we're taking
this guy's this piece of [ __ ] this on
this show all the tires just blew out in
his face of a Tuesday you know he just
you know this whippet cash guys livid
right now
my car eerie hey somebody's coming all
right and you know what you know what
sell this take that take that sign tick
get away game man well there it's okay
Hector's grenada has car there's a tree
in four years I'll blow up into you boom
you know next up on the list is well or
more popular resolutions is helping the
meeting oh yeah yeah so I thought we go
to the local underpass I do unzip the
office and do the opposite and just
murder as many people okay okay yeah oh
there's something there's some day or
days just inches asum just passed away
why okay I'll turn off my life will just
go and scare me whenever yes just go in
just [ __ ] it ed the meteor stupid hey
what's going on where'd you go did he
run away already come back they are so
quick I know the hobos in this game are
just like they just disappear once again
the wonders of crack cocaine whoa that
was the coolest freeze-frame ever oh my
but it was like a frieze of like a
really suave looking elf move this is
like any trying to get a cab I'm like
nears day like come on you kidding me
five in the morning what do you mean is
no good she's only at home support start
to a year ever call an uber dude well
I'm driving the car with my foot oh
sweet fun great footwork huh flinstones
haha yeah I would never do I guess we're
giving up drinking next year so we are
probably make sure that we drink as much
as possible now for the next 12 months
that's right
uh oh [ __ ] is to do here classic classic
what's the hell's going on I was going
on here is that happen to you too [ __ ]
is going on behind this is good is that
a dude in the gorilla suit Ursa legged
is throwing smoke bombs what wash uh
this is this guy's it's my loss and us
is gonna [ __ ] what's happening here this
is some crazy I Shelly's gonna kill me
this is some oh [ __ ] sorry [ __ ] we
should get out of here what's he doing I
don't know there's the smoke coming from
that's really creepy we better get out
of here that guy's up to no good
obviously that was really intimidating
oh he's coming back like hell I can't
get it Artie you lock it no oh he's
right here he's right here he's right
here you thought you fret oh oh you shot
me dead uh-oh some reason our doors
aren't working Oh Santa Santa it's me
hahaha sounds a real Santa's pissed
Jesus he's hitting that list a little
early this year oh nice car Thanks stole
from some idiot alright let's just go
get drunk before this new year comes in
and gonna be really oh hey what's up hey
dude you know I haven't seen a person in
a while so we shouldn't kill him or else
we ruin it yeah we'll be back we'll be
back we'll be back my friend is an ally
hey what's up you give us a discount cuz
we're the only people here one please
you are real bored aren't you give me
energy drinks DJ's on fire though he's
partly this guy this girl is vanilla in
our boobs vanilla but damn this elf
needs some goddamn whiskey right here
yeah I've had all the ways you go what
what's going on why is somebody shooting
me the strip club you just scared away
the strippers you dick where are these
guys at oh oh [ __ ] so much for that lap
dance I can't see it Oh their thoughts
you that's yeah I got bad news where we
going we're going to the store of here
we're gonna spend a whole buttload of
money on some beer great he just saw
whoa he's he's not gonna serve well
notice two of them what the what that is
too he's this guy's out he's like I'm
out of here I'm out oh [ __ ] alright it's
done UK about this I'm gonna follow the
clone I'm gonna see where he goes okay
the great idea Oh homeless guy hey happy
new year oh he wants to fight me oh oh
oh god he just owned me help hold on a
sec oh I got him now what he just
disappeared no oh my god oh no he's just
a teleporter we got him with the
burnetts on his corpse and I I'm gonna
have a beer you've earned it gonna hit
you you know I'll give me a beer Oh
jumped your beer oh oh sorry I'm back
hang ten all right Danny so I think
things about time we dropped the ball
great but that is is that time of year
it's approaching midnight I guess yep
you're gonna sticky bomb this truck
right and then um we'll do the will do
the ball drop pic yet with the cargo Bob
that's perfect and you'll you'll be our
sacrificial ball yeah I love it not my
fault no not at all it would be my
pleasure my honor in fact god I'm so
proud of you come on you got it here we
go here we go that's it that's all
that's it up oh I can feel the new year
best of the new year cheer you can feel
it in your body so for you to detonate
this are you gonna have to also jump out
um you know I actually don't think so
but I'm gonna jump out regardless okay
here we go and you are you're pretty
heavy man yeah with some weight ya next
year january i'll start taking care of
my stuff then all right we're all I've
lost Santos to see dropping the bowl
okay let's see if this works happy near
everyone happy new year danny and may
God bless your soul
oh nice work oh thank you very much it's
been an honor happy to your rub oh god I
can't wait to take off this stupid elf
suit hahaha see you in twenty fourteen
here in 2014 by an hour happy new year
you